hi i'm sofia vergara i'm simon cowell
and this is the
wired auto complete interview yes
[Music]
these are the most searched questions
about us and they're real yes brilliant
[Music]
all right you want to go first well yeah
it's a sofia vergara
age did sofia vergara move to america i
think i was
23. yeah i moved to miami it's very
close to where i come from but it's two
hours and 15 minute plane ride and so i
started working for univision is that
right yeah i didn't know i had a
traveling show i went all over the world
it was amazing at that age i didn't you
don't get dead like when you're 23. what
has sofia vergara been in well the most
important thing i've been in is agt
thank you then modern family of course
for 11 years do you have a favorite
agt
really modern family
[Laughter]
next question what awards has sofia ever
got a won well i haven't really win that
many i've been nominated for four emmys
no have been nominated to sag awards how
many of you won how what did i win i won
five saga worth you didn't know that no
i forgot there were five
for what for modern family for being
gloria preached what does sofia vergara
like to do i can answer that what do i
like to do eat i do i love to eat yeah i
love
coming to work on egt you do i do i
think it's one of my favorite jobs i've
ever had and i love dogs i love my
husband my son i love traveling i love
jewelry i've learned a lot about you
there
what simon cowell what was simon
cowell's first job i was a runner on a
tv show
what did you do run
just everything you do everything when
you're a runner you basically do
everything okay whatever you're asked to
do you just do
and they pay you nothing so that was my
first so then you learned to do
everything yeah that's why i'm a very
fast runner i got shouted out a lot
so you weren't good at it i smashed up
one of the cars in fact i got fired the
pas liked me so much they paid for my
salary so that you stayed yeah and every
time the boss arrived i had to hide
under the desk you should write a script
about like that sounds like a comedy it
was fun
yeah i liked it what bands did simon
cowell created i don't like the word
create discovery i would say put
together worlds apart five
west life one direction little mix fifth
harmony ill divo so quite a few diva i
loved el diablo a lot which was your
favorite i can't say okay okay what
shows that simon cowell judge pop idol
american idol x factor got talent
that's it i think i remember the first
time i came to do an american show
everything was like 20 times the size of
what you do in the uk that's the big
difference everything's bigger and we're
more fun what is simon cowell
like in real life charming interesting
funny kind passionate
surprising
intelligent
humble
that's it oh sorry oops
and i'm also a killer yeah oh good more
sophia vergara one more was sofia
a news reporter no
no i was not what that was good
go to dental school yes i wanted to be a
doctor but that was like the next best
thing can i ask you a question you have
doctors vets
you have dentists can you train to be a
dog dentist well yeah my dog i take i
take to the dog dentist but your dog has
veneers
is sofia vergara an entrepreneur yes i
like businesses i love creating
opportunities for myself
[Laughter]
let's close that one up
as well
i mean i try not to wait for someone to
give them to me but yes i love
making money and making deals she does
sofia vergara's best friend me it's
simon cowell
that's it that's it for me
i have
like 20 cousins that are my best friends
okay with us okay
simon cabo
i did the wrong one simon cowell's first
appeared on tv oh gosh it was a
it was some weird game show and you were
a contestant i was a contestant no yeah
i swear to god but why were you doing
that thing i can't remember i i was
thinking what it was oh i thought you
were doing that in the tv no no no no it
was like anyway i got a call will you be
a contestant on this show and i will
yeah singing no it was like some weird
game show anyway i turned up one and
then i won a second time and then i won
a gardening set or something but then
you loved it you got hooked no i didn't
like it uh unfortunately it's still
around on going home to google that's
for sure simon cowell upbringing
you're upbringing what does that mean
how you were brought up oh how you i was
brought in or raised right well with a
mom and dad but we're in a farm in a
fall
and i don't know where sort of in the
country
my dad was in property
my mom used to be a dancer but uh yeah i
was a really really bad cute kid yeah
yeah i never went to school i was really
really naughty yeah but look at you now
it's fine yeah nothing strange how did
simon cowell became a record i didn't
become a record i think there's another
word sphere missing
that's why i stopped being a contestant
on game shows
[Laughter]
well i never was a record producer you
were a record i was a record
i actually don't know which is true how
to make a record because when i decided
i was going to be in the music business
i never wanted to learn how to make a
record because i thought if i learned
how to make a record i'm going to listen
to records like a music producer how
long has simon cowell been on agt since
2016. six years only yeah oh yeah i
thought you were here from the beginning
know how he's been the one from there i
tried to get on i couldn't even get on
my own show wow
you're one of the favorite with me i'm
trailing behind you
i've just renegotiated my own contract
so i'm here
actually 17 years another 40 years
i'll be being wheeled on
62.
is america's got talent audience real
yes americans got talented in israel yes
it is americans got talent
what is the golden buzzer it's the
golden buzzer it's the golden buzzer
it's the most then you go straight to
the finals what is the prize for
america's got talent one million dollars
and a chance to appear in the las vegas
show which is agt live at the luxor
america's got talent best auditions
there are so many we can't tell them we
said actually earlier on
probably cody lee night but top two
i miss so many you're right america's
got talent parmesan song
i hate to admit advice you like it now
you like it yeah i don't like it all
right thanks everyone thank you guys
[Music]